today my show marks top 10 movies of
2016 the year that was yes right now on
fat men on Batman
welcome to fat men I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark Barnard and if you're one
of those [ __ ] are like I'm a BuzzFeed
baby man give it to me at lists I can't
absorb information unless it's in ten -
number one today's your lucky what we do
for you we're gonna do marks top ten
movies and later on we'll do my top ten
movies but in this episode marks top ten
films of 2016 now some people like I
give a [ __ ] mark barnard and go [ __ ]
yourself mark barnard I'll have you know
will go [ __ ] himself
I'd I'll do it right now if you need
them but he for the right amount this is
the opinion you care about the [ __ ]
you know what movies were the worth
watching in 2016 or we're seeing now
that we're in 2017 works for the LA
Times yet it's the the movie stuff is
the TV section that wouldn't make sense
the [ __ ] film section so he's seen a
lot I've seen left the job you've seen
Malo no nobody can seem to see them all
thank God I still have to go home and
like be with other humans and you can't
do that if you have to see five movies a
day so you don't even necessarily seen
everything so if something's not on your
list it's not it's not really like
that's a piece of [ __ ] exactly no I mean
girl on the train is not on this list
because it is a piece of [ __ ]
ya know that's not a good movie watch
what's the last night fresh in my mind
there's my favorite part though was the
like every cuz when you get the the
Oscars through the war screeners it says
every like ten minutes on the screen
this screen is for awards consideration
only never has that been more satirical
the first I love Emily Blunt everybody
loves me some able to keep it blunt
around here we spoke the Bloods blunt
man who smokes the blunts we smoke the
blunts
rollin blunts but I don't think so I
don't know I mean she might she does a
lot of work like there's a lot of like
pretending to be drunk or maybe being
there's a lot of history onna crying
there's a lot of running with furious
intent well you got to remember she was
this is not the Emily Blunt show but she
was nominated for that Devil Wears Prada
movie so they already like her they want
to give her an award I mean there's a
lot to like just this movie is not the
vessel for her I'm gonna you know what
let's make a gentlemen's $5 bet I think
she will get nominated and I'm not
necessarily saying like I think she's
amazing she should get nominated but I
do think she's gonna get nominated can
we make another bet yes I decide that
side bet I will bet you a dollar that we
can make Jacy super rich and then super
poor and he'll like the ride oh let's
trading places this [ __ ] we can
gamble with his life for the be the best
that'd be fantastic Duke's we would
explain to him what a BLT is such as a
bacon lettuce and tomato sandwich hmm
orange futures the eighties sure he is
still but he hasn't made a comedy it
seems like no no that's right man he
[ __ ] that's I mean King akka if there
is a dude tomorrow that I would like to
see on stage doing stand-up it is that
guy as much negative funny movie just be
[ __ ] Eddie Murphy again yeah maybe
Eddie Murphy we fell in love with in the
80s Wow
he's like I look I never stopped being
Eddie Murphy I'm just not doing that
anymore right which is also fair like
I'd be in any Murphy to himself I'm not
sharing it with the rest of us and that
sucks
yeah [ __ ] you Eddie Murphy do you give
us more Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy I mean
it's not quite as bad as like Sean Penn
in Fast Times is brilliant yeah never do
that again
last time he ever did comedy it's like
you you're gifted give it to the world
no [ __ ] you I'm gonna punch cameras and
marry Madonna's do you think there's
would you think there's like a kind of
well you know that's comedy and anybody
can do that I'm a serious actor
I guess or do you think its level of
like I can't ever like that's iconic so
why bother trying to seduce another you
know funny stoner performance because I
will you know he's been funny in movies
but just not these never done a flat on
purpose all right but it is all that we
digressed right off really talk about
marks got a list or John list Lord nice
one go the men's ten through one right
start with number ten I'm so I'm due to
honorable mentions first o things that
did not make the list marks overly
generous doesn't understand concept of
top ten okay top 14 14 10 don't count
the handmaiden this film by Park
chan-wook Korean director who also did
old boy which you should absolutely
[ __ ] see if you haven't seen sympathy
for mr. vengeance this all vengeance
trilogy that he's done this is this
incredibly ornate and one of the crafted
like early 20th century Korean Japanese
chamber movie that is also a heist film
that is also a lesbian love story that
is also about a love for perverse books
that is also about growing up poor and
underprivileged and seizing whatever you
can do to make yourself make your way in
the world it is this wonderfully
constructed puzzle box of the movie that
has all of those things and it just
keeps exploding itself like every 20
minutes it's a different movie yes it's
and it didn't make the top 10 but you
should absolutely go see it or rent it I
think it's a Amazon things you might be
able to stream that many layered like an
onion indeed if I had to but yeah I mean
it's just and it's it's a banquet of a
movie a banquet of a movie weird and
wonderful and gross and and rich and
perverse and yeah you should watch this
movie I mean just so minute I mean
subtitled yes so you have to work a
little oh now now [ __ ] you
English handmade I just gave a hand job
to the handmade hand man gets a hand job
all right so that's one honorable man
what Zootopia another honorable mention
came in in February it's hard to
remember that come out this year yes
[ __ ] love that movie super strong
that would probably be in my top 10
oh my god I cried during that movie that
movie is so [ __ ] good yeah
their performances like you know I know
there are an animated Fox and bunny but
I thought Jason Bateman should get
nominated for a perform for some sort of
performance award I thought he was
incredible man and the other go I don't
know her stuff but she is great too I
mean it's really strong performance wise
it's one of those animated movies that
is absolutely for kids but totally says
something different for adults mmm like
it's very much about tolerance is very
much about race relations is very much
about the two Americas that we seem to
be living in that we didn't understand
existed before November they called it a
zoot opions yeah very much Nostradamus
this is what you will be ready we all
laugh look at these funny animals in
Zootopia that could never be us that's
that be in my top 10 this one was a it
was a really close one but Kubo in the
two strings they like that you tell like
then we talked about her once before but
this this like stop-motion animated
movie set in Japan this kind of lyrical
fable about this boy who's the son of
the daughter of the Moon King who's
trying to get his other eye because
there's other I will let him see into
tomorrow with a future whatever gives a
[ __ ] it's just so [ __ ] beautiful it's
it's this like wonderful boys heroic
fairy story made by hand
hmm like you know hundreds of thousands
of different and another hand job it's
the is this directed by the guy that did
James in the Giant Peach no that was
army Selleck I believe this is Travis
Knight but in the same total same mode
same vein he's like of the same company
same guys but Travis Knight the son of
Phil Knight who invented Nike oh really
yeah like the guy who created the
[ __ ] sneaker the guy created the
speaker the nawafil
the Nike billions have gone to his son
wanted to have an animation company his
son actually put
the time and went to work for the same
company they do the PJs whose name I
can't [ __ ] remember but yeah like and
also did the the California Raisins yeah
went to work for that companies our
apprentice eventually bought the company
cuz well that is yes bought the company
refashioned it into Leica and it's now
making these movies that nobody else is
making because he's got the money to
spend to make these movies like it is
the height of patronage is what do you
need to make these things have it Wow
and make me make me wonders and then the
last honorable mention is Manchester by
the sea which yeah like if you were
feeling good about the day and don't
want to anymore then you can watch
Manchester by the sea because you will
be a blubbering wreck by the end of it
tearjerker as they say tearjerker but
also I mean and I and I honestly think
that Casey Affleck is gonna win Best
Actor this year really I do
because part of it is because I don't
I'd give him a Best Actor Oscar for that
Dunkin Donuts I'm not smoking in Enda
[ __ ] done [ __ ] love Duncan guy I'm
like the man oh my god him with a
cigarette out the door gone I'm not
smoking but yeah it's performance yeah
it's just it's so just wonderful actor
do is we like to look at Gombe be gone
he's so [ __ ] good in that movie that
was the assassination of the Jesse James
by the Coward fragra for the very
awkwardly tiny movie he's wonderful
Mattie this seems like this might be as
year yeah and it feels like it's it he's
been wonderful for a while but it's
still the oh [ __ ] he's this guy like
there's a surprise element to look how
good he is and has been under our noses
for this long feels like this is this is
the time when he gets that that should
be early Casey Affleck or watch Jason
Amy mmm that's the earlier Casey Affleck
watch the race with the Sun really
Eliza scoop yeah I said like the solar
panel racing thing we built a solar car
or good Wuhan
Chuck I wanna double alright we're gonna
fight we got snacks now those the animal
mentions now or two the ten to nine to
ten number ten it's the longest movie of
the year if you're judging simply by
screen time Oh Jay made in America no oh
the documentary the documentary from
ESPN films but it's seven and a half
hours long first played in theaters or
qualifies for Oscars so it's technically
a movie but more people I'm assuming
have seen it on today play all seven
hours they did yeah in a row there's
[ __ ] me yeah it played at Sundance
all seven hours seven and a half hours
it screamed all seven and a half hours
and then it did the qualifying run over
the summer for two weeks in theaters
where it's all seven and a half hours of
this thing that's a commitment that's a
sit yeah really talk about binging in a
theater yeah but it is no no all right
take a piss break piss on door [ __ ]
today you'll make hot pockets I've got
my easy-bake oven with me you should
plug the [ __ ] in in a [ __ ] movie
theater but it's it is this amazing look
not just at OJ Simpson who is one of the
more documented figures of the 20th
century but of the the sort of the
systems that created Oh Jay Simpson the
the cultural systems the racial systems
the the world of LA at the time and how
all of those things together gives birth
to a person who thinks he's above the
law who thinks he's above race who
thinks he's above penalization who
thinks that the world owes him things
who thinks that he is the victim of his
own success and it it paints the picture
of both the conditions and the result of
this kind of experiment that was Los
Angeles and being super [ __ ] famous
and the first legitimately black person
to be that famous was OJ Simpson and
yeah it's just it's this wonderful look
this deep penetrating look with access
to almost everybody but it is absolutely
worth
the time not in a row break it up
go do some [ __ ] I don't know pause enjoy
life go back make it up make a few
nights yeah I mean six hours seven
nights seven and a half really a [ __ ]
week watch the oj thing and then [ __ ]
yeah I'm sure nobody has ever said that
quite as romantic as you might think it
is break it over the I'm a married man
we spread a lot of programming out over
many all right that's number two that's
number 10 number 10 number nine number
nine
rogue one a Star Wars story we like this
movie a lot we like this movie a lot
I've seen it now three times the last
time I said was in the 40x theater in
the LA live one day for DX for deal also
with a chair move the chair moves and
the [ __ ] like the rain comes down
that wind when you're flying over the
beach on that opening scene like the
wind is blowing on you when you're on
the the shuttle platform and it's
raining the rain is dripping from the
ceiling for DX
yeah get a chance to see a movie in this
it's amazing the chair moves as this
camera moves and [ __ ] blows at your face
and you can smell things yeah insanely
wonderful that's like a butcher's know
in the movie mmm its nose in the theater
which is pretty nuts so I've seen the
movie three times now and we talked
about it on our first to go around for
me like the story holds up less and less
the more I see it
but the thing that I loved about it is
it makes me feel like it's a Star Wars
movie it gives me that that that Eastin
sort of like nicotine high of holy [ __ ]
um nine again and I'm seeing Star Wars
again it feels like Star Wars at this
point that's what I want from these
movies is to make me feel like it's Star
Wars name and even if I have problems
with the story and I'd have come to have
some problems with the story how does it
make you feel and it makes me feel like
Star Wars I don't know my favorite
[ __ ] moments in cinema this year was
large and then the [ __ ] moon tan teen
for dropping into space oh my god I was
in a theater [ __ ] screeching at the
top of my lungs you know at the Pantages
for the
because it just tied in so [ __ ]
perfectly it was the ultimate fan film
you know as if fans not just one because
it was a group effort on this movie
apparently but a bunch of fans said this
is what I would want to see in a Star
Wars movie and they were right on every
aspect no aspect of that movie run like
didn't [ __ ] need that some people
like I need to see [ __ ] a walrus man
and the guys like we got the [ __ ]
death story I'm 12 systems I'm like are
you [ __ ] nuts he didn't need to see
it but like who gives a [ __ ] it was cute
they were in they were out all of it was
wonderful fanservice man but like that
one minute and it's less of darth vader
in the hallway yeah i mean is is one of
my favorite minutes in cinema history
dude like remember that's Hollywood they
would have put that [ __ ] minute like
in that show and me as a young kid I
would be like it is a perfect [ __ ]
minute of cinema yeah that reinstates
Darth Vader as the galaxy's biggest
badass makes you forget about the little
boy in the desert and Anakin Skywalker
no it erases [ __ ] no yes somebody
pointed out recently though that you
could eliminate Oh Erik Carrasco the guy
that wrote my Supergirl lives and so for
Supergirl
he loves the movie too but he was like
you know you could have lost that first
Darth Vader scene on Mustafar mm-hmm and
it still would have yeah didn't need
that at all not at all it's like really
nothing accomplished there it gives you
the one moment that everybody picks on
words like don't choke on your ambitions
but if that scene doesn't exist and then
the first time you see Darth Vader's
that's the whole line marks in the
hallway and it goes apeshit for a minute
you probably would have had the same box
office the same effect and whatnot
glad we have the extra scene because
it's like most afar but totally
eliminate but yeah I mean there's week I
could pick on this movie if I wanted to
and you know you find me at a bar
somewhere and I will but I'm still
[ __ ] mad at dinner so yeah tell me
some [ __ ] I calls her Jenna [ __ ] like
you're spilling your drink on my mark
if Galen can get out a hologram of his
own [ __ ] name and his message why
can't it with the plans on that [ __ ]
thing why not
yeah there's there's there's holes in
there and that's fine and every movie
has its flaws and its faults and if it
if it moves you you don't give a [ __ ]
and you know it move me you know what
they made Star Wars stronger by and not
just the Star Wars universe but Star
Wars the mothership stronger by being
like oh they meant to you know the Death
Star was built shitty so that they could
blow it up you're like oh that's amazing
right
all right that's nine so that's nine
okay number eight I'm going back to
Korea back to South Korea for a film
called train to Busan it is it's one of
those things where it's a zombie movie
okay it's a zombie movie filtered
through the sensibility of another
culture which you don't get that much
really because zombies are a inherently
American invention you know so to watch
like a story about a father who's this
kind of like wage slave who's out of
touch with his kid who wants to take her
back to her mother whose kid they're
divorced but they get stuck in a train
that happens to me infested with zombies
it is so [ __ ] fun because again it's
a train full of zombies as bullet train
full of zombies barreling through the
South Korean countryside just and is it
ghost-like snowpiercer but with zombies
it's just every go car to car to car to
car to car and meeting these people and
seeing a little bit of their stories and
following their father and his child as
they're trying to get to the head of the
train where there are no zombies before
it gets into the station that's just
perfect little genre exercise that I was
so surprised by this summer like I just
saw it on a lark trained in the song
train to Busan and it's streaming now
it's might even be on Netflix but
absolutely like it's worth it's like
maybe five minutes long and it's just
this crackerjack little zombie thriller
perfect yeah do that
that was number eight that's number
eight number seven Oh
of course god it's so I guess that
wasn't this year that was for a golden
yeah yeah man Deadpool was the [ __ ] yes
I mean and it does that thing that we
always say is be the best version of you
that you can be
that is the best Deadpool movie that
Deadpool can be pyridyl I yeah like it
doesn't have to pretend to anything else
it doesn't have to try to do anything
else it is 100 percent Deadpool and yet
did something that nobody else has ever
done yeah it was perfect
yeah no I love it to death and I I
haven't seen it since February but so
much of it still holds up yeah like it's
on the HBO's now so I'm charming is it
[ __ ] but yeah all good things and super
happy for those two guys yeah I bought
some Miller in Ryan Reynolds all right
that was number seven that was number
seven number six hell or high water
oh you saw this man I did see that he
[ __ ] looking at the screen or gone
and I like Chris Pine and I like Jeff
Bridges what absolutely like I saw it in
the theater like late August early
September and it was after like the
parade of shitty movies in August and do
certainly be the tail into July it was
such this wonderful bomb with like this
is a real movie like this is actors
performing this is well done
storytelling like it's this sort of neo
Western set in in Texas about these two
brothers played by Ben Foster and Chris
Pine who are robbing banks and only
banks that have held their mortgages
basically it's we're getting revenge
against the the sort of cratering of the
mortgage market by robbing banks that
have held mortgages and then we're going
to use this money for reasons that the
movie will then make clear but and then
Jeff Bridges plays at Texas marshal
who's gotta hunt them down I thought it
was their dad yeah but it's this this
really great portrait of like desperate
America of you know people on the
fringes on the edges just trying to claw
themselves a little bit of what they
feel there
and it's also Jeff Bridges is like the
last ride of this old sort of Texas
cowboy just trying to bring in the
fugitives one last time and Chris Pine
is really good like you don't forget
because he's playing Kirk for a little
bit yeah remember him in smokin aces
like this kids a genius yeah like
there's like there's these moments of
him where you're just surprised a little
bit the same way we're talking like
Casey Affleck were you like oh [ __ ]
you're actually really good at this
that was half of my response to hell or
high water was holy [ __ ] Chris Pine is
great
he's really really good and I like his
Curt hell or high water economy job
that's your job that was number six
number six you're gonna have to come
back next episode oh yeah we dangle it
out there first teeth throws it on the
table lets it wobble and then you gotta
come back for it just put the rest of it
in your mouth so come back next episode
Marc will do five through one the five
best movies of 2016
indeed on the very next episode of fat
man I'm Batman until then I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark barnard come back next
episodes ain't that time save fat chance
podcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you